who saw Hamilton one wants to Hey yes I
have a good idea we're gonna do
something competitive on the way down
and the two people that win I will buy
you tickets to celebrate our birthday
each year take the team somewhere back
the competing on the softball field the
basketball court and the egg toss is a
great indicator a lot of people think
playing and enjoying but what they're
really gonna be doing is getting
analyzed
and then capacity and volleyball come in
we had nothing to say
seems like you was not hired and bm1 and
fired and bm7 that was tough
I got carry a Diet Pepsi snapchat
exclusive interview by the kids I got
hit by a mouthpiece so please tell
everybody your name and what happened
I'm Andrew Forbes I was booing staff
because he got a six ball his mouthpiece
hit me in the face and thank you very
polite a more apologized but young lucky
Steph Curry is that that wasn't me that
he had I would have went I would have
first of all massively over me and
basically trying to get me suspended
I would have been super and you tell
everybody how famous you are you know
what happens next
you think that every single person you
walk by knows who you are that's what
I'm going through down I just look at
everybody's eyes and like like that
woman just walk is our office do you
rock her out surely clearly knows what
she's doing I really wish you lost the
hit camera
the rapper finals
no let me get the memo this is the
craziest [ __ ] I've ever seen
that's a matter of evening sighs he's
got real swag hi my name is Eric green
Miller Heiman group director at
vaynermedia Gary was giving away tickets
to Hamilton which I have actually it was
fortunate to see once already
who saw Hamilton one wants to good idea
we're gonna do something competitive on
the way down and the two people that win
I will buy you two hi guys my name is
Kenzie levy I'm an intern at vaynermedia
this summer and I'm working on the
design team and we were just kind of
playing a game on the bus and Gary's
like let's do something competitive
let's have everyone pick a number
between 1 and 1000 I do like the idea of
he picking a number from 1 to 1000 and
people going around against it
I had a number in my head and I could
just feel that it was the right number
he was basically picking a number
between 1 and 1000 my number is twenty
six twenty two and 563 794 756 629 I
picked 575 because five is my favorite
number little did I know that it's also
Gary's favorite number so that was
pretty cool and I was lucky enough to be
within ten what well 13 something that
I'm not gonna create in that but I'm
pretty excited that I'm getting a chance
to see Hamilton again
so thank you so much Gary I really
appreciate it like I'm so like a little
bit shocked about it I got to sit next
to him on the bus like this isn't really
an ordinary internship obviously as you
can tell like this is like the best
opportunity of a lifetime overall I'm
just so excited to be here
celebrate the seven year anniversary
with all these wonderful people that
I've met so far everybody who gets the
number under a hundred raise your hands
who gets the number in the 500 raise
your hands
you're the three finalists Eric's second
number was in the 500 which is a really
interesting fun fact all right Eric
you're number one more time 575
the correct number is
5:55 I'm gonna what's your five which i
think means you're out right cuz you're
575 within 20 and your five the two
winners stand up go to back go to the
backing bus let's get every other bus
very jealous these two people these two
people just won tickets to Hamilton in
our bus game
that was fun
Q&A is like I want to create with you I
want to share a message so it was that
me and you'd like you want to model for
me and do not mind getting messy
babysitter killed three of my birds is
her cop
Oh
sorry I pulled over
it says no trucks exactly no buses
good job you rock alright now that we
found them less scared he said 552 do
you guys hear young kids Hulk Hogan
sorry young kid goes to the bathroom
just looks over he goes that's weird
what's up brother everybody's got
completely sucked into spending enormous
amount of time on snapchat right that's
like that's like pretty much happened
how many people here are using Instagram
a lot less than six months ago because
of snapchat raise your hands
using Instagram last because of snapchat
over the last six months raise your
hands just want to see it again I think
we should go back
I've never had a smoothie never got
around to my fun fact is my hair on fire
like a few years ago when I first
started as a child I refused to sit on
shampoo I was like 5 years old my fun
fact is actually pretty controversial
like you're not like avocados
that's what Boehner eight years gonna be
we're gonna take a seven-hour bus ride
in one direction and then just back on
buses we're a full-fledged big high
school
it's amazing huh
yeah I know what I can eat ham turkey
sandwich right
I don't know why do you yell you said no
so much there's so much I could say
there's so many feelings you have when
you're building something but I uh but
I'm personally very excited about where
we stand and where we're going and
excited about this group that's here I'm
excited about the group that's coming
over where we're going we can do this
because we're more talented than
everybody like the reason we can be this
is because we're more talented we're
just better we're gonna win anyway we
can win being nice to each other just
gonna happen
their legacy of what we're building is
real and like it drives me the most and
and I'm really really really really glad
that we get to do it together